You know, on, on Reddit we can get any page in
JSON, or we can also get it in XML by changing
our extension. And a lot of webpages have this feature, where
you can get their content in different formats. Another good example is
Twitter. If we were to go Twitter and do a search,
let's look for udacity, we can see all of the tweets about
udacity. Now, if we want to get a JSON listing of this, I happen to know the
URL. We can go to search.twitter.com/search.JSONq=udacity.
And now we get a JSON listing of the search result that we
were just looking at in Twitter. If you're writing web software and you want
to manipulate another website or get data from another website, you know, it
usually just takes a little bit of poking around to find their APIs. Now
the way I found this API is I just Googled for Twitter API,
and this was, you know, the documentation for this came up. I'll show you
that real quick. There's this whole page about you know, twitter search API. One
of the nice things about when you're building websites is if you have data.
You know, if let's say you have a blog. Making your blog
so it supports RSS. You know, an XML representation of its content, and
maybe JSON representation of your content, or else other people to build
software on top of your website, that, that can do equal things. And
so, many large websites, Wikipedia, Twitter, Reddit, all support this types of
functionality, and your homework in this class is actually going to be, to
add that functionality to your book that we've been working on. Just something
to be aware, most users don't really see this side of the Internet,
right? It's really only other developers get to
see this APIs and these other formats for
the content, so it's cool that it's all there and it's good to be aware of it.